جددت الخارجيه الايرانيه تمديدها بنشر
مجله شارليب دو الفرنسيه صورا وصفتها
بانها مسيئه للمقدسات الدينيه والسياسيه
الايراني كما قال في بيان ان ايران تدين
ما سمته التقاعس المستمره لسلطات الفرنسيه
في تعاملها مع مظاهر عادات الاسلام ونشر
الكراهيه والعنصريه في الصحف والمجلات
الفرنسيه
وحملت الحكومه الفرنسيه المسؤوليه
المباشره في خرق مبادئ الحريه وحقوق
الانسان ودعتها للتعامل بشكل جدي مع
المسؤولينا عن نشر الكراهيه اكدت الخارجيه
الايرانيه انها ستعيد النظر في تعاونها
الثقافيه مع فرنسا والنشاط الثقافي
الفرنسي في ايران وتتعمل كخطوه الاولى الى
ايقاف عمل جمعيه الدراسات الايرانيه
الفرنسيه في ايران وكان طهران قد استدعت
السفير الفرنسيه لديها وبلغته احتجاجها
على ما نشرته تشارلي ابنه
ينضم لنا من طهران مراسل الجزيره نور
الدين الدغيري اهلا بك نور الدين تضعنا في
سياق هذا القرار من الجانب الايراني فيما
يتعلق
بالازمه يمكن وصفها بازمه ثقافيه لان
تتعلق بشؤون ثقافيه
نعم عبد السلام يمكن القول بان الخطوه
الاولى في الازمه بين طهران وما بين
باريسيا ازمه ثقافيه باعتبار ان الحدث
الذي انطلق من فرنسا نصرتهم مجله شارلي
ابدو وهو كما تراه طهران نوع من الاعانه
نوع من الاساءه الرموز الدينيه هنا
والرموز السياسيه
ما سمتها اهانه
للمقدسات يبدو ان شر لابنه من خلال
عنوانها البارز هي في محاوله للتضامن مع
مسمه حركه النساء
رد فعل ثقافي صدر من الخارجيه الايراني
ستخلص من تعاونها الثقافي مع فرنسا وكرو-
ثم ايقاف المركز الدراسات الايرانيه
الفرنسيه
لكن يبقى السؤال دائما هل يمكن ان يؤدي او
تؤدي هذه الرسوم الى ازمه السياسيه او
ازمه دبلوماسيه ربما همم فصول هذه العمليه
قد تتبين خلال المرحله الاولى اذا ما توقف
خلال المراحل المقبله اذا ما توقفنا عن
طبيعه ما نشر في شر لابنه خاصه انها صوبت
بشكل دقيق سهامها على الرجل الاول هنا في
ايران وعلى المرشد الايراني علي الخامنئي
كان محطه سخريه من مجموع من الصور التي
نشرت هناك وبالتالي هنا حينما تتعاطى
طهران مع هذا الموضوع تتعاطى على مستويات
متعادله خاصه في شخصيه المرشد الايراني
هناك همم شخصيه المرشدي يكون الرجل الاول
السياسي الاول هنا في طهران وصاحب القرار
بالدرجه الاولى النقطه الثانيه التي تعامل
مع طهاره تتعامل مع المرشد الايراني
وبالتالي هو اهانه لشخصيه دينيه كذلك هنا
في قطارات والاهم من ذلك عبد السلام هو
المنصوص عليه دستوريا الايراني
هو توصيف الولي الفقيه وهذا التوصيف لا
يعتمد فقط على معيار سياسي ولكن على معيار
فقه يجعل هذه الشخصيه تدخل بالمنظور
السياسي الايراني الى ساحه المقدسه
وبالتالي فاي اهانه او اي اساءه لهذه
الشخصيه بالمنظوره الايراني هي اساءه
للشخصيه دينيه بالدرجه الاولى ولشخصيه قد
تدخل كما اسلفت سابقا الى دائره المقدس
الديني هنا الى دائره المقدس السياسي هنا
في ايران وهذا ما يترتب عنه ورود الافعى
لذلك كان بين الخارجيه الايرانيه واضحه
حينما فرنسا المسؤوليه الاولى عن هذا
الحديث حتى وان كانت
صحيفه او مجله لا تتبع للحكومه الفرنسيه
الايراني
على المستوى السياسي وكذلك على المستوى
الشاب الشعبي هل يمكن ان نشهد تحركا شعبيا
وراء باتجاه السفاره الفرنسيه او باتجاه
المصالح الفرنسيه ربما هذا يبقى محطه
انظار خلال المراحل المقبله شكرا جزيلا لك
على كل هذه الاضاءات نور الدين غير كان
معنا من طهران